die app tik tok ist nun schon eine ganze
weile der heiße scheiß unter den social
media plattformen was die inhalte auf
der plattform angeht sind die meinungen
gespalten denn einen gefallen sie nicht
so gut die anderen finden sie komplett
ich für meine wenigkeit muss zugeben
dass ich mich der app tik tok sehr lange
verschlossen habe erst im august letzten
jahres habe ich mir die herunter geladen
und bin seitdem schwer abhängig viele
menschen da draußen hätten da muss ich
ehrlich gesagt bestehen kann ich mich
nicht ganz anschließen ich finde man
sieht auf tik tok wirklich sehr sehr
interessante sachen teilweise man sieht
die erlebnisse und den alltag von
menschen die man sonst niemals zu
gesicht bekommen würde man lernt neue
sachen erweitert seinen horizont aber
dann
dann gibt es auch noch den einen oder
anderen tik tok trend der ein bisschen
über die stränge schlägt einer diese so
genannten trends und derjenige treibt
mit dem was heute in diesem video
beschäftigen werden ist der small ways
pretty face bigbank trend das ist eine
web line aus einem song also der song
ist eigentlich so normale rap song so
irgendein typ rappt über mord und drogen
so ganz normale sachen und irgendwie
fremd über also andere sachen wie sie
ihr geld verdient und so und hatte noch
vereine leiden wo sie sagt costa de
swayze face with the big bang
ich mache ich konnte mal vor wie der
tanz gps kameras bisschen tiefer stellen
aber es gibt ungefähr so denn thanos ist
kein hans so ist einfach small base man
trägt auf seinen wake für die fans da
macht man den und dann dann kommt der
grund warum diese ganze sache ganz so
krass geheilt ist und zwar auch mit
leute so ist es ja es soll weltweit mit
der türkei sind wir ganz ehrlich wir
sind mitten im lockdown so keiner von
uns hat mir einen fremden fax zu geben
hat er sich doch warum aber ja so
funktioniert dieser trend und auf diesen
trend springen einige mädels auf die in
der hüfte gegend überproportional
geformt sind und wie wir uns aber
vorstellen können gefällt das ganze den
männlichen nutzern der app tik tok
relativ gut aber jetzt habe ich genug
erzählt leute schau rein das ist
wirklich super leute ich zeige euch mal
das beliebteste video unter diesem trend
8,7 millionen likes muss den sound von
dem video bisschen bearbeiten den
koppelt aber schau mal rein
das ist irgendwie so ein ding auf sieg
doch ich weiß auch nicht warum aber tik
tok schafft es immer wieder immer wieder
irgendwelche trends herumzubasteln also
man nimmt irgendwelche sachen opel eins
auswischen songs länger da geht es nicht
mehr um irgendwelche es ist so da geht
sie sagen bigbank disneys pretty face
mutter bigbank bigbank bank bank die
redet über ihr geld so sagt sogar also
ich hab eine schlanke hüfte ein schönes
gesicht und ich hab viel geld schickt
absolut nein wie diese diese leyen geht
eigentlich um geld das das geht daraus
können wir keinen trend machen es muss
sich irgendwie um erträge und deswegen
ist dann eben der trend entstanden bei
dem man halt das macht das eben gemacht
habe ich mache euch nochmal vor allem
eine bank auch sehen wollt smart way
pretty face und dann einmal den sprung
bigbank
übrigens was ist ihr gehört meine
freunde sitzt mit im raum und sie hasst
diese video idee auf jeden fall perfekte
ausrede für mich in videos und shampoo
woher weißt du weißt wie es kann
angeschaut habe was wirst du das bitte
mal mehr ist nicht mein handy direkt
heute habe das geschäft ich schaute auf
meinem handy gerade an und sie erkennt
wie hast du kannst nix videos schaue da
wird direkt kontrolleur welches
widerstand er sich anders ja also
fraglich genug warum mädels das machen
so ich meine jeder kann mit seinem
körper das machen was er will jeder kann
sich präsentieren wie er will kopp es
schlau ist sich in dieser art und weise
dem ganzen internet zu präsentieren ist
wiederum eine andere sache aber die ja
dann auch noch gut ich denke ich bin
nicht die zielgruppe davon okay also
checkt das sind einfach nicht also man
muss dazu sagen man muss dazu sagen ich
kann verstehen warum jungs die nicht in
einer beziehung sind anders als ich das
eventuell interessant finden könnte die
jungs die in einer beziehung unter
spreche auch für alle da draußen alle
jungen szene beziehungen sind alle
freundin von jungs dieses video schauen
junge singer beziehungen hassen diese
serie
die haben sich noch nie diese diesen
trend angeschaut werden auch in zukunft
niemals tun also müsst ihr gar nicht
danach fragen aber ist schicksal wichtig
also wie ist das entstanden mann der
ursprünglich von bankguthaben ok um cash
auf dem konto und liegt doch so nö
nein nein es muss sich um ersten dreh
eins muss ich dabei aber auch
klarstellen ich bin auch kein hater der
ganzen sache ich habe jetzt gerade wie
gesagt schon mal glaubhaft und
glaubwürdig dargestellt dass die jungs
in beziehung keinerlei interesse an
diesen videos haben selbstverständlich
aber es gibt dann auch wieder so andere
männer diese trends sehen und sich so
krank drüber aufregen was so andere
frauen somit ihren körper machen das
schickt wiederum auch nicht ob mir hier
rein
[Musik]
also vorher ein erzabt frauen sagen
einerseits so dass man sie nicht
sexualisieren soll andererseits markt
nehmen sie an diesem sound teil so egal
hör mal ganz kurz zu
warum kannst du nicht einfach genießen
kannst du dich einfach genießen die
klappe halten also ich nehme jetzt mal
an dass er single ist ne wäre er einer
beziehung dann wenn dieser satz
natürlich krank gelogen und
geisteskranken behauptungen wider
so warten sie aber ja er ist halt ich
nehme an er ist nicht in der beziehung
nicht das stück ja wiederum auch nicht
heute warum hätten die dann so warum
hätten die dann so also ja okay es gibt
also so eine ecke von männern ich war
früher auch mal so ein bisschen so wie
also kein erfolg mit frau und ein
bisschen verzweifelt sind deswegen
frauen auch irgendwo her denken ist mir
böse oder so aber ich checke das einfach
nicht da so was wenn ihm der
weihnachtsmann ja wirklich den fettesten
karren mit weihnachtsgeschenken
vorbeifährt rudolf du reindeer das
rentier vorne dran ok vettel den kann
direkt nach hause das haus dann würde er
sich noch über das auto vom
weihnachtsmann beschweren
wieso ist das ein ganzer trend leider
also ich kann einerseits verstehen dass
diese videos bei jungs ziemlich krass ab
gehen ja dass sie dagegen komplett
getrennt einmal durch schon wenn ihr ein
video davon sehen single jungen das wie
gesagt aber andererseits ist das genug
sind rennt einfach so dicke nochmal also
diese taktik dabei so auch so krass dass
man so krasse sachen sieht oder krasse
tänze oder krasse veränderungen oder so
ich sag ich mal täglich krass findet wo
ich mir denke wirklich das ist ein trend
wert so was hier finde ich krass das ist
so der trend der soweto einem skater
live ist nightmare wo leute halt so in
fotos nachstellen und dann sind es so
uns eigentlich alten kinderfotos das
finde ich überall kommen ja
[Musik]
wie geil ist das der leute das doch bis
heute ist es voll schön man sieht okay
die kinder sind groß geworden so alle
sind happy miteinander das ist doch geil
und dann andererseits muss ich jetzt ich
mach jetzt nicht noch mal okay bigbank
stellt euch einfach vor sich jetzt 180
grad im kreis springen okay lass mal
kurz überlegen dass meine sehr feinen
damen und herren war der heutige
einblick in die neuen sozialen medien
von dann lass uns einfach der stelle